good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast
we hope you guys are having an amazing
day happy thursday that feels like a
friday
for everyone who has off or is taking
off for the wonderful holiday weekend
the 4th of july so exciting 4th of july
weekend
can't wait like this weekend even though
it's a short one
this morning like felt like it should be
a friday and for us it is and i actually
don't even feel bad that we
are taking off tomorrow because we have
left you with
so much content this week look at my cup
look at my cup
it just runs it's over and it's over
okay here's what here's what we have put
out just this week that you can consume
if you're feeling rdhs weekend beyond
the four episodes four episodes of the
toast
free available on all platforms video
and audio one
podcast patreon episode with olivia all
about
miss kaler and motherhood and you know
postpartum depression
and i don't know if you've listened to
the episode yet but you obviously have
not
because there's a moment in there that
is so deeply offensive
to me but is such a compliment to you
um and i know you haven't heard it yet
because like you would have called
olivia crying
i haven't heard it yet i'm gonna listen
to the podcast in the car make everyone
listen to it
i've heard it's right around episode 3
minute 20.
okay so there's that extra podcast
there's a vlog
patreon my get ready with me i am on
mood with lauren elizabeth this week
so good so much wellness like it's just
really the kick in the butt you might
need
and then also a new episode of the
redheads just dropped today like there
is content content content you guys
like we said earlier in this week
podcast podcast podcast content content
content
meetings meetings meetings so we have
left you with literally even though you
guys are so busy like getting [ __ ] up
that's fine just want to let you know if
you're looking for us
tomorrow or monday there is a plethora
of things in which
to watch and choose and listen there are
so many places to find us
so i feel really good about that and it
makes me really excited to head out into
this holiday weekend
yes i'm very excited to celebrate kelly
ripa's favorite holiday
i'm really happy for her um i know
she'll be in the hamptons and we'll be
reading all about it in hello magazine
come tuesday morning
yeah i feel like i feel like whenever
there's a holiday weekend i don't
actually have like
a plan you know i'm just like never
making plans so i'm so excited because
we finally like made a plan and now i
can really like look forward to this
weekend as opposed to like me laying in
my bed all weekend
which is also like don't knock it like
an amazing way to spend your weekend no
but i had a recent weekend like that so
i wasn't looking for another one
yeah i'm so excited to just like be with
the fan be with kay
be out in the sun even though it is
supposed to rain which is just so
annoying this will now be like the
second holiday weekend this summer that
it has rained the entire time memorial
day weekend it rained
in like the tri-state area the entire
time it's supposed to rain the entire
time this weekend except for sunday
so i've got my cards against humanity
bring your kindle
bring your oh my god i have to like
actually pack like a full
bag of rain things like kindles decks of
cards code names
yeah i don't know some recreational
drugs like anything to just like have
fun you know
yeah no i totally understand and so
unlike yesterday where there was really
nothing to talk about
there is so much to talk about today the
stories run this
over and you know what today's story is
today's theme is injustice yeah there is
so much injustice in today's stories
that
i think i have to hold my gavel the
whole entire world in the world and
we're going to bring unfortunately bring
it all to you there is one small
bit of justice news global justice it's
not even justice news it's like
obvious duh human rights news yeah it's
just
no i was talking about the woman from
tour de france oh i was talking about
the olympics breastfeeding is that a
story the woman from
all right no not the woman so if you
want to talk about her update from the
this happened yesterday while we were
live on air the woman who we reported on
earlier in the week who totally [ __ ]
up the tour de france and then like fled
her country and her big yellow coat
um has been found and she has been
arrested so justice
has been served a little bit of justice
but like still those bikers who worked
so hard
injured for her dumb ass signs how do
you say justice in french
justice yeah liberta like it's um part
of
egalite yeah yeah oh ready justice in
french
justice justice
justice let me make sure i put that in
my english to french yeah justice is
justice english detected
france justice right that doesn't look
great la justice
where'd you see that right right below
but it's justice
that's logistics is probably the justice
yeah yeah okay good well
justine's has been served yeah um
how was your day yesterday my day
yesterday was busy i was editing the
redheads which was such a fun task
because the episode is so amazing so
please go check it out
redheads book club you don't have to
have read the book in order to listen to
the episode i do a nice recap
at the top and you can just enjoy but if
you are into reading i think
everyone will like the book um we all
really like this book i know you watched
a lot of too hot to handle
i watched half an episode of too hot to
handle oh i watched
i started episode two and by like three
quarters of the way through i was just
like
this is stupid well that's so crazy i
had like such an opposite reaction like
i was like this is so good i don't know
maybe like i've just changed so much
over the last year like from the last
time i watched you hot to handle
or maybe season one was just better and
brought you in
way faster than season two but i was
just like this is not
a good use of my time this is a waste of
my time just
i ca i mean the concept is is cool
whatever but on the one hand
it's not enough money well so that is
it's not enough money to make it
interesting
yeah and i think it really should be the
hundred thousand dollars
per person and everyone gets deducted a
million dollars and split and then i did
like how lana was like
it won't be split equally yeah you know
she was like everyone
will get what they deserve based on how
they performed but it's also not fair
that some people have absolutely no
[ __ ] connections
so there's no temptation for them it's
not right it's not like they're existing
yeah no that's a hundred percent true
that nobody's into them they're not into
anybody i agree the
the fatal flaw of the show and we even
last season which was really good we
said it when we recapped it like it's
just not enough money to make it
interesting
and i think they don't even really make
it clear if it's a hundred thousand
dollars for the group or a hundred
thousand dollars per person i think it's
pretty
clear that it's for everyone right for
everyone and it's not enough i agree so
even if
you were perfect a hundred thousand well
first
what is there twelve of them is there
twelve or is there ten let's say 10
that's 10 000
per person after taxes it's about 5 000
depending on where you live
and i just feel like it's not
life-changing money it's not something
like you're gonna
stay celibate for no but i also can't
relate to these people who like
just have to kiss each other like and
like have to [ __ ] all the time 100
percent who literally
can't sus with staying
with withstand withstand wow i never
correct you
with stan for even one minute yeah
have some self-control have some
self-control so i just but that's not
what bothers me about the show it's just
like an
aside i just feel like i'm not maybe
because i've just gotten on this journey
like this historical journey so many of
the shows that i watch like i learn so
much
and they're entertaining so now it's
like if i'm really not
getting anything out of the show i i
can't i think you should continue on
it's really good
really yeah and you might have just been
in like a bad mood or something i really
wasn't i was actually in
quite a good mood i was waiting for a
housewives of beverly hills i was
chilling with brew
but it was like hey ma i never saw
season one could we watch it oh maybe
that's why
i was like bro come on just give it a
chance it's like a fun silly show
no it's like not everything has to be
historical fiction like but like even
i watched some like some yeah dumb [ __ ]
real housewives
and so good luck or like siesta key but
like
there's something more interesting about
it to me yeah i think that
you might have just like watched like a
bad 30 minutes because the first four
episodes like
are really good they are okay for you
my sister my co-host
i will give it one more chance i will
get to the end of episode
three okay that's so fair okay um i
finished
sex life and i have to say it is
such a bad show and i think everyone's
like a lot of people are like loving it
and like girl we know why you're loving
it like
you don't lie like we know the the sh
as a show like as a plot oh my god it
was so stupid it didn't get like kind of
juicy at the end it was like drama with
the neighbors
are you gonna finish it i i mean start
it i i actually
want to okay the ending was so
frustrating like because basically the
whole time's like girl
make a decision like just whatever it is
i don't even care
just stick some choose something and
stick with it yeah and then like
literally the ending is so stupid like
it's actually really frustrating because
she's just it's it's one of those shows
where you're watching someone [ __ ] up
their life like her life was perfect
and if you're unhappy in your marriage
for whatever reason like then leave your
marriage like don't be such a drama
queen like running to the city
every five minutes acting like you can
get there in 30 seconds when we know
you're taking the train like yeah
so it was just very frustrating and i
hate watching shows where like the
protagonist is self-destructing because
it's like
okay if you want to make bad decisions
that's fine but like make the [ __ ]
decision
the whole show is limbo like what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do who's
she gonna choose who's
and then in the end it's like i don't
wanna read it but like don't ruin it
don't ruin it i think probably people
are watching i'm going to give it a shot
but knowing that they're dating and like
watching it through that lens which we
reported on yesterday in case you missed
yesterday's episode which you really
should watch because it was hysterically
funny it was
brad and um billy are dating i actually
can like really feel the chemistry even
though it truly is like a lifetime
original movie community theater level
acting
yeah except that guy brad is actually a
very good actor yeah i mean he's been a
lot of stuff
everyone else is giving me major
hallmark vibes i those are vibes i can
appreciate which is like everything that
you're saying to like knocks they show
are things that i you will love like you
will love it
that's why i'm gonna give it a shot so i
finished it um and then i went out for
dinner and i just had a lovely evening
came home watch real housewives of
beverly hills we're gonna
recap that in the tv recap segment after
the past five and
you know what i watched last night
because i was like i was watching tv
until pretty late
i was watching bff's pod
with jeffree star jeffree star oh my god
you know i need to watch it
so it was really good you're such a
grandma bff's pod
that's what it's called it's the bff's
like podcast sounds like uff's podcast
they're they're just like username is
bff's pod like
okay well i watch like i i catch that
show when they have a guest
which i like want to hear from because i
feel like they are have a really good
interview dynamic and so it was really
nice to see
jeffrey again i know he's like being so
m.i.a so m.i.a so like they talk about
all of that
and um it was it was really enjoyable
because like jeffrey
i really missed him me too what did he
say like any bombshells
not so many bombshells because they were
sort of like catching up with his life
like they had this whole pamphlet and
like just sort of taking it from the
beginning because i think like
like dave like knows jeffrey of course
they've sort of like been on the
internet for as long as each other but
like
what how exactly did you get from here
to there so um if you're like a jeffree
state you pretty much know everything
but it's always interesting they talk
about like kanye and stuff but
yeah it's just like funny and it was
nice to see jeffrey again like looking
so well
and honestly i've seen a few episodes of
bfs pod but like i'm obsessed me and
margo are obsessed
with brianna chickenfry then you'll
really like the episode because she's
really the star of the interview and i
feel like
jeffrey has an appreciation for her
because i feel like she's the only one
who like knows like what he does
yeah yeah and i could explain to the
other people like what really happened
yeah i follow her on tick tock and like
just like want to be her like live in
the east village you know
yeah and yeah literally um
i need to watch that actually yeah it
was it was really enjoyable
um there was some more drama in the
youtube space yesterday with the
frenemies update okay and it's like at
this point they've gone back and forth
so much like nobody even cares but
trisha like
put on a full-blown apology video um
basically saying what
everyone's been saying this whole time
how she really disrespected ethan she
was so rude to the crew
she broke her trust with ethan like
because she like aired a lot of his
dirty laundry
and basically she just said like she had
been on you know she struggles a lot
with mental health that she has bpd
um oh sorry that they were on um
like a new medication and honestly the
video just
it was so late it's like we really don't
okay but she's
taking ownership of the way she behaves
she's not sticking to this like
no but she she's been making videos
literally four weeks up until this point
defending her actions like to the t
okay and now now she literally light
switch
new new perspective do you think it's
genuine
i mean the video seems genuine but like
this is classic trisha seem like someone
who says stuff she doesn't
mean but like this is kind of like i i
think the
roller coaster of emotions that you go
on when you're a fan of trish like
she kind of says one thing does another
and then this
is just like a complete opposite and
what she was saying was i agreed with
everything she said like
she feels so bad not only because of
like she loved doing frenemies but also
this is a family and she like loved
being a part of such a big family
she is a small family but she loves her
family and it was so nice to like have
passover she said it was like the best
passover she ever had
so it was like there were there were
really earnest moments in
someone sounds like someone needs to
outstretch an arm i know but like
trisha has just like really done them
dirty so many times like i don't know if
i could
ever forgive trisha one time for
if she did that to me and ethan and hila
have done it like a few times and like
this is really
the last straw so based on the video do
you think that frenemies will come back
no and that's not even what she said
she's like i don't even know if i want
freddy's
to come back i just want to say my piece
and like
try and course correct okay well that's
nice to hear
yeah but like i'm so over that drama
like
it's so such old news and the fact that
it took her what did we talk about that
like three weeks ago
yeah to apologize like no yeah
no no no damn i'm sorry claude it's not
gonna work out for you
it's okay i mean i wasn't even really a
huge fan of the podcast i was more of a
fan of the drama
yeah that's how it goes yep so it goes
so that's your podcasting news update
and i think without further ado
where are you he's not here today
because claudia said that ben's working
from home so
do is working from home as well he
needed to do it
yeah hit him up via email if you're
looking for him he's still on email but
he's just taking
the day off you might get a bounce back
like t-h-e-o-o
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and that's true but before we dive in i
just want to say how dazzling i'm
feeling today do i look
dazzling you do look dazzling i'm
feeling dazzly af
thanks to shoedazzle shoedazzle by the
way i wore these shoes that i got from
shoe dazzle to a wedding in the hamptons
like
two weeks ago and i've never gotten more
compliments in my life on instagram and
in real life about my shoes and they
were from shoedazzle
shoe dazzle really has like the most
sickening shoes like check it out
basically how how you get started is
you'll take a quick style quiz for
personalized outfit recommendations
make sure to enter your email address
once you take the style quiz and then
you'll receive exclusive
access monthly deals and updates about
new collections that haven't been
released yet
you can shop from hundreds of styles
curated just for you
you can also choose to check out as a
guest or become a vip member which has a
ton of perks
you could save up to 30 all day every
day you get early and exclusive access
to new styles collections collaborations
they do sick collaborations with like
different celebrities and influencers
and also as a vip member you get
exclusive sales and promotions
so if you want to check out shoedazzle
go to shoedazzle.com toast to get
started
it's a decision you won't regret i
promise it's shoedazzle.comtoast
check them out like seriously you owe
plots from the selection of sickening
shoes
sickening shoes dazzling shoes i'm
taking so many with me
this weekend because also i love shoe
dazzle because they're affordable enough
that you can really have a pair like for
every outfit
yeah you don't have to like that's like
that shoe dazzle commercial when
the wife had like all these shoes and
the husband was like why and she was
like because they're so affordable and i
literally have one for every outfit that
was a really compelling commercial yeah
no that's how i feel um
my outfit's cute today but i need i need
to put the blanket on i'm sorry
are you cold i am cold i'm really
feeling good it's chilling
okay first story the big news of the day
bill cosby has been freed from prison
after court overturns
sex assault conviction america's dad
turns sex fiend bill cosby can we stop
calling he is not our dad
like my dad's dead and bill cosby is my
not my dad
okay so sex fiend bill cosby was
released from prison wednesday afternoon
looking feeble but flashing a peace sign
hours after his sex assault conviction
was overturned in a stunning
court ruling this is so crazy this is
like
i thought we were like the chapter had
ended i wasn't even thinking
i brought him up on the show yesterday i
feel like i put him back in the universe
yeah i had literally forgotten about him
i know i thought i didn't know the book
was still open here he was freed from
sci phoenix after spending about two and
a half years behind bars
on three counts of aggravated indecent
assault involving accuser andrea
constand
he had been sentenced to three to ten
years in prison
in addition to constant five other women
testified at trial that cosby had drugs
and sexually assaulted them too
and scores of more accusers have stepped
forward over the years to accuse him of
everything from sexual misconduct to
rape
cosby himself admitted in a damning
deposition in a civil suit constant had
filed against him years earlier
that he liked to drug women before
having sex with them
the problem was that cosby had spoken to
prosecutors under what
both sides said at the time was an
immunity deal that allowed him to dodge
criminal prosecution in the case
that's like this is where i don't
understand the justice system like you
can literally be on record
admitting your crime but it doesn't
count um
because the court ruled that that
immunity on what he said like
under those pretenses had to be upheld
and that his conviction
had to be tossed because of because his
conviction was based on a lot of the
things
not i'm just trying to explain as best
as i can
how this happened yeah i didn't even
know that like we were still appealing
i didn't know that like there was any
legal draw i thought you know we threw
him in a cell and threw away the key
like i didn't know that we were still
talking about this
yeah um and like it just all happened so
fast
overturned and he's home like it
literally happened in 20 minutes yeah
it's vile it's disgusting and honestly
like
i don't know like this is just like for
all those women who like went through so
much to like speak out
it's like all for nothing like are you
serious like this is so and it's not for
nothing but like
to have all of that work be undone is so
disrespectful and it's so unfair
it's so so upsetting like such a
miscarriage
of justice of justice for all the women
who did come forward and this was
one of the first big stories that really
blew up the metoo movement
and so to have that courage to tell your
story
and for this to be the end result is so
upsetting
this would be like like you're right
bill cosby
the the story is as big a part of me too
as like harvey weinstein yeah that would
be like harvey weinstein getting out of
prison like so [ __ ] unfair
yeah and not right and not just no so i
know like
now i don't foresee bill cosby getting
back to work
he is in the court of public opinion by
most people
considered you know irredeemably bad
yeah but it's not the same as what he
deserves which is
being in jail yeah well i hope he
has a miserable life same and i hope his
accusers
victims can find some peace and they
feel i'm sure they're like feeling
unsafe
like it's just there's so many there
must be so many things going through
their mind
and i'm really sorry like that [ __ ]
is just
wrong wrong wrong no no no no not the
news that you wanted to see yesterday i
saw a funny meme it's like we said free
britney
not free bill no i know and that leads
into our next story
because we didn't even get to free
brittany nope the judge has denied
britney spears's request to remove her
father from her conservatorship
again a judge has shot down britney
spears's request to have her father
removed from her conservatorship
at least for now new court documents
that were filed by the la superior court
on wednesday show that the judge has
denied
a month's old request by spears's
attorney to remove her father jamie
spears as her sole conservator
so the good news is that this is not a
result of this most recent trial these
documents are not in direct response to
last week's hearing where spears gave an
explosive testimony
those fears delivered a powerful
24-minute statement the judge cannot
make any ruling based on what she said
as she's still yet to file a petition
to terminate her conservatives all
together yes so there still is hope
this obviously just came out as bad
timing because most people just read the
headlines and it's like okay she gave
that speech and this was the answer
yeah but i just find it you know as
someone who holds a gavel
i really find it disgraceful that
now two judges bill cosby's judge and
britney spears judge
have failed the justice system and i
take a lot of pride in holding this
gavel yeah and i just wish my peers
would do the same
no honestly the gamble means nothing
today no it's like
meaningless it's just a piece of wood
really literally
colored i mean i'm glad that like we
still have hope because when i first
read this i just automatically assumed
that it was like in regards to the big
drama from last week
right it's very confusing there is still
hope but again it's it's a loss
for team brittany especially because
there are all these
people concerned and there's different
reasons why people think that like the
judge and like so many people
in the legal system as it re
regards refers to britney's case are
being paid off by the conservatorship by
the family and so like this just
fuels that conspiracy theory like yeah
why wouldn't like why are you so
obsessed with
jamie spears like why is he why
why is he better than all other
conservators like you know what i mean
why are you so
like hooked on keeping him i don't know
maybe because you're lining your pockets
with britney's money maybe
speaking of money great segue to our
next story erica jane has been ordered
to turn over her financial records in
tom jordan's bankruptcy case
honestly the legal news all of these
legal stories we need to get law degrees
to report the news these days no if
celebrities are gonna keep committing
crimes we're if you're gonna be a pop
culture commentary
you need to go to law school a jd is
that what it is
i don't know that could be it i think it
is that sounds right yeah i don't know
no md's doctor okay dds is dentist
jd degree judicial degree right like
a juris doctor degree is the first
degree in law yeah
jd like i need to because i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on in any of
these cases
yeah i know and maybe celebrities could
just stop committing crime
right our jobs wouldn't be so [ __ ]
hard
no literally like i would have studied
harder for the sats if i knew that this
was going to be my job
no like we would have gone to law school
if we knew that being maybe we should uh
or like um maybe we could do like
university of phoenix
skillshare yeah or like university of
phoenix yeah yeah i think we need to
take some like
insurance law for dummies literally that
would be a fun activity
we'll fly around okay
real housewives of beverly hills fans
will finally know how expensive it is to
be erica jane the reality star was
ordered to cough up her financial
records
as part of her exchange estranged
husband tom
girardi's bankruptcy case per court
documents obtained by page six on
wednesday
jane's divorce attorney larry a ginsburg
was ordered to produce the records by 5
pm on july 21st
oh she's got some time yeah however the
star may be able to buy some time as she
was given until 4 pm on july 16 to file
an opposition to the order if necessary
well honestly i don't know what these
financial records are going to show us
because you know watching last night's
episode she basically was like
you know i know what tom's done in his
other two divorces like i'm not getting
any money and she was like pretending
like she was okay with it
and we know erica jane would not be okay
with that like she has said multiple
times i've been rich and i've been poor
and i'd much rather be rich like
she talks about how she's obsessed with
being rich and so i don't think erica
jane would take that so lightly
in a divorce had she not known that like
literally they had
no money she had to have known okay
that's a really good point i just will
say
i think that it's not like she's leaving
tom and has nowhere to go she has this
gig on real housewives of beverly hills
that
is only made stronger by this divorce
she
is a star is a star like she i mean now
with the legal troubles
she's gonna have a hard time you know
being a brand ambassador
but before when she left tom she had
everything if she
anything she wanted to do she could have
done she was vogue she was on broadway
no you're right she was literally like
the it girl of the fashion
yeah like i think she's like read by cia
like whatever she wanted to do whatever
she wanted to endorse she could have
done that so she would have just been
making her own money
and i think that's what she was starting
to say to lisa no no
when she was like when i was in new york
i was on my own and i was like and she
was like and i was really on my own i
think she meant like paying for whatever
hotel she was at
and she was like and it wasn't so bad i
know but there is a difference between
the type of money erica makes as a
socialite
and the type of money and lifestyle you
get being tom gerard's wife and so
i think that erica had made peace with
the fact that she's not getting money
whether she stays married or not stays
married because he's
broke and so yes she could pay for her
owner's house but she don't have two
planes
she doesn't have a closet upon closet
with racks and racks and racks and racks
are clothes and perkins and chanel
she doesn't have that but she could pay
her own rent and take herself to new
york i just want to say
maybe fly first class i just want to say
we haven't seen the planes in a few
seasons
and by the way thomas two planes he
really couldn't hop on one and see his
wife perform in new york
and i'm not saying he doesn't have two
planes but maybe they're company planes
i don't think erica was just like
oh i think i'm going to go here she was
using the plane like
at her leisure over the course of her
time on the show like
she took the plane to go pick up yolanda
in cleveland
her first season it's been a few years
since then things change
you're saying we haven't seen those
planes in a while that's true that's
true
two the racks and racks and racks of
clothes a lot of that stuff
is gifted a lot but not most
i think a lot of it is awesome it's not
like everything she wears
is louis vuitton like no she wears a lot
of like moschino and some like
more fun streetwear streetwear brands
that are more into gifting influencers
so i think it's possible that like yes
she has to buy the expensive
stuff but she gets so much stuff i think
that
trail has ended though i don't know well
now with the legal terms but when she
left i don't think she had to choose
between her wardrobe and her marriage
when she left though i think she knew
all of this was coming that's what i'm
saying
so that's why she's acting all cool on
the show about you know
whatever tom's gonna give me nothing but
i'll start on my own tom's gonna give
you nothing because tom's got nothing to
give yeah
that's what i'm saying so her financial
records i don't even think they're gonna
show us that much we know she got 20
million dollars to ej global her company
from tom's law firm the money of orphans
and widows
um i just don't know what these
financial records are going to kind of
expose yeah i just think they're
important to tell the story
yes this is just so messy
also there is the theory that they
divorced in order to
take the money so if he gave erica the
money
and then she left and now they're going
after him they need to see her records
to make sure that's not what's happening
that's it that is it because that was
the consensus when they
filed for divorce on election day
everyone was like all these lawsuits are
coming up
it's a it's a they're very much still
partners and they're in love and they
need to protect the money and if
if they're divorced yeah no 100 yeah so
i think that you
have to turn every stone they gotta turn
them stones
do you think erica jane has like 40
million dollars just sitting in her bank
account that tom gave to her so that the
feds couldn't take it from him
that would be the craziest thing of all
and the most
unethical thing of all because there are
all these people in line waiting to get
their
restitution from tom gerardi and eric is
just sitting on it buying homes and
purses
that would be [ __ ] crazy yeah ooh now
i'm excited
yeah okay are you ready for our next
story a little more exciting housewives
news exciting housewives news that's
brought to you by hair food
yeah hair food offers simple superfood
inspired products that will make your
hair look and feel amazing
whatever hair texture or hair type you
have hair food has a recipe for you
in addition to their beloved nourishing
coconut milk and the chai spice
collection
you've got to try some of their new
recipes the apple cider vinegar herons
which is perfect for days when you need
a gentle cleanse
the tumeric and almond oil detangling
milk which takes care of the most
stubborn knots and it reduces frizz
in this heat wave you best be using the
turmeric and
almond oil detangling milk because we're
getting sweaty we're getting naughty and
we're getting frizzy
they also have the shea butter and pear
color and pear color repair concentrate
which can make over processed hair look
vibrant and healthy so if you color your
hair and it's kind of broken and damaged
that would be really good for you
all the products smell so good and
they're free of sulfates parabens dyes
mineral oils and they are certified
peta cruelty free so if you're looking
for nourished healthy hair it's got to
be hair food
look for it at amazon walmart and target
thank you for that claudia you're
welcome now i feel ready to let you know
the exciting housewives news which is at
the real housewives of potomac season
six taglines are here
finally literally the only franchise
that has been stellar
for the last like i i think about this
all the time mostly because we talk
about it all the time
this most recent season of potomac was
the best season of housewives
maybe top three best housewives seasons
ever and then also every franchise was
like
flailing because of covet so it just
made it look like even better so to me
like real houses of potomac is on such a
pedestal right now
and we they deserve all of our respect i
know but i'm struggling
because of the injustice towards monique
i know and now candace is still sticking
around janice is still on the show
and like i it feels like the denise
richards situation like it's so unfair
no justice and i'm i'm gonna watch but
like i i
know that i'm truly conflicted no that's
true because i so
stand with monique i stand with monique
and not only that i so don't stand with
candace like i just
i really don't like and i really hope
that there's one of these women i think
it could potentially be ashley darby
who doesn't let it go just like giselle
doesn't let denise go no just like just
like garcelle doesn't like it
just at least i'm staring at gizelle's
tag just like garcelle doesn't let lisa
get away with it yeah
okay read the taglines first up gisele
the secret to this pretty face is
staying in the shade
that's pretty good that is so on point
because she is stunning
and she's so so shady like really
wrapped up her personality like stunning
and annoyingly like a pot stirrer
yeah and like self-aware shady yeah i
also hope gisele gets what's coming to
her because
the way she really stirred the pot
really
like [ __ ] up last season and then got
her ass [ __ ]
handed to her by monique in the reunion
like that was stunning
and there's so much like you know
chitter chatter online about
jamal and like the cheating like because
monique really blew that thing wide open
and then like the blogs so
i'm really interested to see what
gizelle has to say for herself i really
hope giselle has been like humbled a
little bit and will stop getting up in
everyone's business
when her business is very messy i think
monique's firing
was a win for giselle i don't think it
was humbling for her i don't think
monique was fired
monique not returning to the show
doesn't matter she's not there to keep
coming for you
yes it's last man but can we all
disagree monique left the show on her
own accord because she doesn't need the
money she doesn't need the fame and she
doesn't want it to affect her marriage
yeah
okay okay and by the way there's no one
i have more respect for
in the world than a housewife who can
and does walk away there's so few of
them
bethany monique i guess denise
denise yes to me like it's the most
respectable thing you can do
and deandra was actually when she was on
our show she said something really like
that
actually made me respect the hell out of
her because she's like you know i have
so much fun but every housewife has an
expiration date
and when it is my time like i will not
be too proud to just go
yeah and she's like i'm having fun i
know this isn't gonna last forever and
i'm like that is such a good attitude
because
so many of these women cling to their
fame
on the show they cling to it so hard
because it's everything they have now
their whole world revolves around the
money and the filming and
when you get that taken away from you it
can be devastating so you have to have
like a really good head on your shoulder
so and i think
monique does yeah ashley darby the only
thing messier than two boys is me so
cute i hope i really hope she does get
messy because she
for the last like two seasons has been
on the right side of history mess it up
ashley we're counting on you i'm really
really counting on ashley and karen
karen yes ashley is kind of like our
last like soldier on the ground like to
really
take care of candace yep karen huger the
grand dom can never be duplicated
imitated or intimidated iconic like i
don't even care what comes out of kevin
huger's mouth
like i just [ __ ] love her so much 100
and so whatever like you want to call
yourself whatever you want to say like i
don't even care but that's pretty good
wendy this professor doesn't just grade
on the curve
she sets the curve that's actually
pretty cute but it's just like
we professor again like that is her
whole personality her first season
and it is something to be proud of but
like this is a tv show like
yeah i don't want to be reminded of
being graded on the curve
yeah like oh no i'm back in a college
lecture now like it's just
i actually have ptsd from it ptsd
no but wendy does need to evolve a
little bit outside of the shell she
created for herself in the first season
um it didn't help that she was so on the
wrong side of history
um but she's gotta give us something
more like than the professor
yeah okay robin dixon claudius
[Laughter]
i may keep you waiting but trust me i'm
worth it
no you don't keep us waiting no because
she's late she's so late she missed a
flight
like she's all the latest i thought she
meant because they were waiting for her
to like be interesting no
no no i thought because like we're
waiting for her and juan to get married
that's what i thought oh i thought it's
because she's always
she is wait what is it again i may keep
you waiting
but trust me i'm worth it i disagree
actually i don't know if it's and i
would also just amend that to say but
trust me i'm worth the wait
just to like bring no i hate when you
say a word twice in a sentence okay but
you said wendy said curve and curve
she did but it didn't bother me like
this one though because it's wrong
because i just
honestly the fact that you know what it
is the fact that robin dixon is still on
this show and
like there have been a women come and go
on the show who even though
if you know even if i didn't like them
were so much more interesting of course
monique like
monique sent on the show but robin dixon
is like make it make sense
charisse like she was more interesting
than robin like yeah
katie ross like there was just so many
and i was i just can't believe we're
still stuck with rob
i can't believe it every season when i
was catching up on potomac last year i
started season one
and i think i caught up to like season
four was where they were at
and i could not believe she made a
single time she was back
and you know what i do feel like there's
a small bit of value in robin dixon if
one day
she ever decides to speak out against
giselle yeah because in a lot of
how i compare it i see gisele as alisa
vanderpump type
and robin as a kyle and like maybe
no that's that's no okay i don't know if
robin said
no but i mean if if a lot of the women
are mad at giselle
and robin then starts to speak out
against gizelle like it could be very
powerful
yes i agree that's what i'm saying
candace my blessings are many and my
patience is none
yeah we know we know we do know that we
do know thank you for the reminder
that you are an instigator or my
blessings are many and my scruples are
not
that's really good she really should
have used the word scruple because
i use it so much ever since things she
ever said i completely agree have you no
scruples
i have been saying that word like so
much since she said it i didn't even
know what it meant when she said it it's
such a good word it's really an essay
word it's such a good word okay are you
ready for the next one oh wait there's
also a new yeah there's a new house
right we're not done oh jackie goldstein
i may be cut from a different cloth but
it's top quality fabric
no um that's like literally my
my favorite and least favorite tagline
of all time
i may be cut from a different cloth but
it's top quality fabric
[Laughter]
okay no new housewife mia thornton if
you want to pop off
i'll be happy to get you adjusted to get
you what adjustment
oh she a chiropractor that's what i was
thinking too okay because i just have to
say
i've watched the trailer five times
could not figure out what me as the new
housewife said i couldn't hear the end
of her sentence
she swallowed it if you want to pop off
i'll be happy to get you adjusted
i think she must be a chiropractor i
think she could have done better with
like the back analogy
yeah i appreciate the reference assuming
that she's a chiropractor
yeah she could have also if she is a
chiropractor and we're like talking
about like back stuff
she could have did like if you want to
talk behind my back
i'll crack it for you yeah like yeah no
i agree she could have done better with
the whole like medical
chiropractical analogy i mean i really
do hope she's a chiropractor right okay
she has to be
she has her degree in neuromuscular
massage therapy
okay yeah that's much better than a
chiropractor
but she's still cracking backs like
she's suggesting
no i don't think she is sounds like she
works with people's brains so she's like
a spinal
no neuromuscular massage therapy
whatever sounds impressive so i just
think she could have done better like it
should have been
she's an entrepreneur and massage
specialist okay so
she's cracking that so she's crying back
to yeah yeah okay those are the
tag lines i'm excited for potomac to
come back but i am conflicted
yeah no i actually didn't think of it
that way i just thought like wow it was
such a good season like it's gonna be so
good this time but you're right like
we as a network we they took the wrong
side uh-huh
the women took the right candy came for
monique so hard in a way he's never come
for
anyone before it was painful to watch it
was actually like
kind of like set off this like this hate
train for me with andy like
i've just kind of really been over him
since then like he shows up to work acts
like he doesn't want to do his job like
he is back in studio and i did watch
like him and sonia morgan and he he's
definitely more vivacious acts like he
actually gives a [ __ ] what the people
are saying but
i'm just like after that reunion i
really could never look at him the same
no i agree like thinking about it
actually makes me upset
yeah i'm just thinking about how monique
probably like had to sit through that
and then like chris came out like
it it must have been just painful for
them and i feel like a lot of empathy
for them
yeah me as well fifth and final story
a little basic human rights news the
olympic organizers reverse course and
will allow breastfeeding athletes to
bring babies to tokyo
that is so generous like i cannot
believe that they would let
breastfeeding moms
feed their kids like that is honestly
it's too much i think we should reject
like i don't think we could accept a
gift that gracious like it's so
unbelievably kind and lovely and i'm
just overwhelmed with
gratitude i really am it's it's too much
it's too much
it is way too much yeah olympic
organizers say they've reversed the
policy that would have prevented
breastfeeding moms from bringing their
children to japan
for the 2021 summer games organizers
have reduced delegation sizes and
prohibited athletes family members from
accompanying them to the olympics as
part of a strict
coveted 19 counter measures the tokyo
organizing committee had previously
denied requests for exemptions
from moms with young children what about
young children
bringing their moms good question too
and you know what when we were sitting
here after
the show yesterday and this news came
out
we were really talking about how many
extra people go to the olympics like
besides the athletes like think about
how much
press goes photographers news cameramen
like
the fact that literally it's not like
it's just the athletes go the fact that
they're being so strict is so honestly
like
when it comes to mothers and children
it's honestly unethical and this really
just makes them look bad
i totally and completely agree and at
the end of the day if someone doesn't
want to go because they are feeling
unsafe because of kobe like no one's
making them go but if they are wanting
to go and ready to take
whatever steps necessary let them go
let them let my people go that's just
like the craziest thing
the craziest thing actually no not the
craziest thing i heard all week because
bill cosby because bill cosby is walking
free flashing peace signs
and disgracing your favorite hand
gesture
no bill cosby no no no
um let's dive into tv recap the real
housewives of beverly hills episode was
on last night not much happened but it
was a really interesting
thing to watch is what i'll say um and
today's episode since it's freezing in
here has to be brought to you by hush
blankets
let's talk about the quality of your
sleep the reality is over 160 million
americans struggle with sleep and hush
is here to help
they sell a wide range of sleep
essentials for every sleeper sleeper
whether you're a hot sleeper a cold
sleeper hush has what you need to get
the job done
they carry anything from pillows and
sheets to their best selling weighted
blankets with
which jackie and i both have at home and
if you're hesitant about getting a
weighted blanket because there are so
many benefits reduces stress and anxiety
helps you sleep
um because you're a warm sleeper you get
sweaty in your sleep they actually have
a collection of iced weighted blankets
that are tailor-made for people who get
hot in their sleep which is actually
brilliant um so if you're looking to
improve your nightly rest naturally
hush is the answer and if you're not 100
sold they have a 100 night guarantee on
all of their products
so try it out for 100 nights and return
it with no hassle whatsoever
they also give back so from day one they
have donated one in ten adult blankets
and one in five kids blankets to those
in need around the world
so you can feel good about your purchase
and also you're just gonna enjoy your
product so much i've had my weighted
blanket for over a year it's still in
great condition
it's like a stunning color a lot of them
look like hospital like medical they're
some of them are really ugly but hush
makes fabulous looking ones mine's like
a royal velvet blue you'll really enjoy
it
so if you're looking to upgrade your
sleep head over to hushblankets.com
and use the code toast for 40 off your
next purchase it's valid on all of their
products so that's hushblankets.com
code toast for 40 off it's the biggest
discount they offer so don't
dumb this out don't sleep on it so very
good
real housewives of beverly hills like
was not that crazy um but there were a
couple things that
i really liked that were like seemingly
irrelevant
when porsha was hysterically crying when
her sister sophia came home like
i actually was getting really teared up
i thought that was really sweet
and obviously just like reminded me of
us and like i just i actually really
i love kyle i think she's a perfect
housewife like i really do um
but her family life is like so sweet and
lovely and i'm just like so happy for
them
totally agreed it was really cute to see
that porsha crying so hard for her
sister but it was also making me so
concerned for the campers like
that whole scene like porsche yes the
bot makes fun of porsha like not going
to school not
like talking anyone has never been to
her new school didn't have a bat mitzvah
season
can't see her sister her sister comes
she's hysterically crying and she can't
even give her a hug i'm like yeah
these campers are not okay you know what
kyle said is i think what a lot of moms
are dealing with like they're kids who
are in this like really important
socially development
yes stage and they're locked in their
house with their parents like
some of them have siblings some of them
have don't like it's really traumatizing
and you could see like porsche's unwell
like
she hasn't left the house in a year
she's scared to do her butt mitch the
speech like she's
literally screaming when she sees her
and that's what the kids of today are
really dealing with that was a very real
scene
yeah very very real when like just her
not being able
to hug her sister i was like these are
this is not good for the campers
yeah another scene i really liked grisel
was just being so
funny in last night's episode like she
was just like really giving me life
um and her home life is turning like
really
becoming so interesting because one of
her dating and two like now that she has
the real and she like does it all from
home and she has like all these
different people in her house
i kind of like live for her life like
that is like what i want to be like
yeah working from home with like this
sickening job and like her kids are
really well behaved and
they like are really sweet and when they
talk about her getting married like it's
actually
[ __ ] like that always bores me but i
actually thought it was really
interesting and cute and when the
kyle fish died it got
no i agree i totally like her personal
life scenes and it makes me think about
last night's episode like
really not that much happened but it was
a good episode like yeah just the women
were doing their things and
i found it enjoyable i have no
complaints no complaints even though it
was boring um
hearing erica and sutton talk i actually
thought that was a really sweet scene
that was
really like a really really nice thing
of sutton to do sutton is such
a warm kind-hearted person she really is
and that's why when she finds herself in
these conflicts it's like you have to
remember that like sutton is not
like the big bad wolf no like she
is a little quirky and stuff but like
the fact that she's won over erica who i
would say these two women like
polar opposites personality wise are so
different
i think it just goes to show that she
really means so well so when
her someone is saying like she did
something in an intentional nefarious
way like
we know as viewers like that's not
sutton no not at all and i really have
turned a major corner on sutton
i do think she's difficult to understand
she's very complex and i feel like i'm
getting to know her a little bit better
but honestly when it come came to the
whole crystal thing like i really
felt like okay let's say crystal took it
the wrong way of course son didn't have
bad intentions
but she's allowed to feel how she feels
but now just kind of going back and
watching all these clips and darite said
it best she was like when i was
being told what happened it was being
made very clear to me that this was like
an intentionally creepy thing she was
acting in a strange way on purpose
and now crystal's kind of backtracking
and if crystal's not going to let this
go
which she's not she's got to stick to
one story and she has not been doing
that
because when they flash back to her in
the sprinter band in tahoe she's saying
one thing and then on the plane she's
saying another thing
and so it's like get your story straight
if you're going to keep talking about
this right and the more she
says here and there and there's all
these flashbacks to these conversations
like the bigger it gets when in reality
it was three-second moment yeah and so i
appreciate sutton like when she first
heard crystal was
offended by it like was so sorry yeah
like when they hugged in the room it
should have been done but then it's like
when you keep going around and saying it
to everyone and you're using words like
violated which i agree with the women is
a very big
i'm not gonna just keep apologizing yeah
like it's done and if you're not gonna
let it go like i'm not sorry anymore
yeah no it's like i'm sorry for what i
did right then but like now i'm offended
by what you've done since
right like going around to everyone
making it seem like i'm a peeping tom
yeah
um also i just think we should all
acknowledge and give out an academy
award to lisa arena for best performance
and pretending to be sad about the fact
that your daughter's dating scott disick
like
lisa's fake concern for the fact that
her seven or
19 year old daughter is dating a 37 year
old man she's such a faker she's like
what do i do should i just ignore it
like and all the women are like don't
worry it'll pass like girl we know
you're
literally doing dances in your house
running around your backyard naked like
we know how happy you are like you don't
have to lie to us like we know you like
i know
this is the best thing that ever
happened to you you don't even give a
[ __ ] that he's 18 years older
than your daughter you're just so happy
she's literally gonna be a kardashian
like that
is we we know where your values are we
know your priorities like be real with
us
yeah i didn't buy that for one [ __ ]
second i also thought it was weird when
she was like at least the press isn't
talking about her eating disorder
anymore like
that was weird the only it was only ever
spoken about because you put it on the
show
you put it on the show like no one was
like really talking about it just like
having conversations about
women no one was talking about the only
headlines were just but it would have
been a recap of what amelia said on
the show so like if if you were upset
that people were talking about it
you put it out there it made no like her
like i was just now buying it
that moment was like a lit too much of a
tell
it was like a crack in her store veneer
yeah literally like it was so
frustrating to watch her pretend to give
a [ __ ] like
we know you're ecstatic just own it own
it lisa own it yeah when they were in
the car i was like happy for her that
she was wearing sunglasses because she
was able
she was like she would have been able to
but she is an actress
so act she does she acted
like and also knowing now like it's
actually not a phase they literally like
live together in miami and he takes
pictures of her
naked it's so easy to get a book yeah um
it's very concerning but it is strange
to have that conversation around
you know erica who dated tom who was 33
years older than her
but erica but erica wasn't 19. right
that's the thing you know you're so much
more impressionable when you're 19
then when erica was 35 and made the
choice 28 28 whatever
a grown woman like but it's just weird
to say anything negative about an age
difference that big when literally
sitting next to erica who was married
for 20 years to a man
double the age gap i don't think i don't
think it's the same i mean it's a
similar
concept but it's not the same thing not
the same thing but it's very similar
yeah um so yeah i think that was really
all that happened last night nothing
crazy but
i did really enjoy it and all the women
are just so rich that like seeing them
at home
doesn't bother me like yeah i find home
scenes in like jersey or new york to be
just so depressing
but watching crystal in her stunning
backyard kickbox while her kid has a
breakdown like
the vistas were stunning you called so
it was really interesting to hear
crystal talk about how she gets styled
because we were just talking about that
top that she was wearing her
professional gorgeous gorgeous with the
three bows and the cutouts and then she
literally said like i didn't pick this
out
and that was just an interesting factoid
that i felt as though i needed to know
and also
makes me feel like next week when um
sutton insults her pants
yeah that it's crystal's not going to
take it that personally no because she'd
pick him out yeah
no and like you know when you always
think like oh i want to be you know
married to a businessman but like i
never really thought that i wanted to be
married to like a really behind the
scenes like disney pixar movie director
but crystal has really opened my eyes
like that's the life i want like yeah so
many perks but you're not like
you know in that [ __ ] up hollywood
scene because you're not like a star so
you have like that
humility and integrity and you work
really hard behind the scenes and you
have a stunning mediterranean style home
in hollywood hills like
i think that if i had to choose a life
of any of the women like i might choose
crystals like it's stunning
yeah and i think there's a lot of
stability yes exactly like there's so
much
if you're like a star like there's a lot
of
uncertainty in that life but crystal's
got a down pat and i'm i'm living for
her
even though like when it comes to the
women she's honestly so wrong
but her lifestyle is just like so
sickening like i can appreciate it
yeah i agree i'm sure that i'm looking
forward to the watching the season play
out i think she really has had a rough
start
i think that she you know stuck her
stake in the ground just in the room
a little too soon the wrong moment um
yeah but it's hard to be a first-time
housewife like it really is
yes sutton had the worst season ever and
it's a really big
cast yes it is sorry was like irrelevant
last night yeah
except for that outfit i know she always
shows up shows up and shows out and i
feel like they've been doing like even
though
because they're still coveting because
this is christmas of last year
and that's when they get covered yeah
that's happening soon they're doing i
think a pretty good job of like planning
these really nice outings like that
hotel rooftop dinner drinks was lovely
like really cute yeah and they're
everyone's hosting something at their
house it's nice yeah i'm enjoying it me
too
so that's that on that there's nothing
on tonight since keeping up with the
kardashians it's officially over
yeah is there anything on tonight oh
well we don't even have a show tomorrow
so
um but no i don't think so everyone have
an amazing
4th of july hope you
stay safe and happy
and healthy don't drink and drive and
that's really all the wisdom i have to
impart
yeah same goes for me i'm really looking
forward to a few days of alarm free
living
this was a an alarm had like this
morning oh my god i waited to the last
possible second
to get out of bed so that's what my hair
looks like
um just everyone have an amazing weekend
this is just like you know
we're gonna miss you we will but you
know what we're gonna meet together
which means patreon content
we're back on tuesday in studio if
you're a member of choice after dark um
hit up the master post because we'll be
together in a house like maybe the chili
cook-off
maybe it's time for round two because i
made a white bean turkey chili
that was so good a few months well you
finally used meat and i think it's time
for me to come
back for ben that's such a good fourth
of july activity
first chili cook-off was so iconic like
i
honestly don't know if we could ever top
it like we might have to do like a bake
off or something like okay maybe we'll
do something else
because we really can't ever like it was
so we were in such good spirits and
everyone was there margo's not coming
this weekend like
it was just so perfect like i don't know
if we should even try to top it like
honestly it's the best video we ever
made
i said great chili cookoff great chili
cookoff and if you are a patreon
member go check it out that'll get you
inspired for your fourth of july chili
but i do think we should cook a chili
this weekend 100 video was like
ben and i come together and we blend
it's beautiful
it's a beautiful end to like the chili
cook-off story yeah it's like we are
competitors
and now we're family yeah thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
hear radio cats box all the places where
we listen to podcast find us morning
toast leave a five star view about a
beautiful
stunning and smart we are have an
amazing holiday weekend we love you guys
so much
god bless america and we'll see you on
tuesday goodbye
you